depuis le 18 juin le vaccin élaboré par
le centre de microbiologie et
d'épidémiologie de gamme et la ja a été
testé sur des volontaires
ceux ci ont été divisés en deux groupes
un premier groupe qui a reçu une dose du
vaccin et le second groupe qui a donc
reçu deux doses de ce même vaccin et
quatre semaines plus tard les
volontaires du premier groupe sont
sortis de cet hôpital avec des résultats
semble-t-il satisfaisant en fait ce
vaccin n'est pas un coronavirus mais il
provoque une réaction similaire dans
l'organisme humain et déclenche le
développement d'une immunité similaires
comme si c'était le résultat de
l'infection au coronavirus il n'y a
aucun risque d'être infecté mais c'est
la même humilité qui doit se développer
comme s'il s'agissait de l'infection au
coronavirus lors des études précliniques
le développement d'une immunité
cellulaire et immoral spécifique a déjà
été prouvée si nous parlons de notre
travail de médecins comme sergei
petrovic l'a déjà dit nous évaluons
plutôt l'innocuité en particulier
l'immunité non spécifique
stefie shock immunitaire l'objectif de
cette hospitalisation vérifier que le
vaccin soit bien acceptée et qu'ils ne
présentent aucun risque pour la santé
des patients
j'étais un peu inquiète pendant une
demi-journée tout allait bien et le soir
j'ai eu de la fièvre
j'ai commencé à avoir froid et je me
suis rendu compte que j'avais de la
fièvre
je les mesures et je les fais baissée et
j'ai appelé un médecin
rien de grave
c'est comme une piqûre ou comme une
injection d'un antipyrétiques il ne
s'est rien passé je n'avais pas
l'impression d'être en feu ou quelque
chose comme ça tout comme d'habitude je
me suis levé et je suis allé me reposer
c'est donc désormais un retour à la vie
normale pour ces volontaires même si
l'état de leur immunité restera suivie
par les médecins
alors on le sait la russie n'est pas le
seul pays à participer à cette course au
vaccin qui soulève d'énormes enjeux
politiques mais aussi financiers en date
du 6 juillet l'om est recensé 21
candidats vaccins qui en sont
actuellement à la phase des essais
cliniques
le franchissement de cette nouvelle
étape est encourageant mais le processus
d'élaboration d'un vaccin est long et
fastidieux
il reste encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir avant que toute la population
ne soient protégés de cette pandémie